Jeff's in Chicago hi Jeff welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show hi Dave thinks for
taking my call um kind of an interesting
different question for you my wife and I
have been able to get rid of all of our
debt except for our mortgage you know we
built a house back in 2007 right the
peak put about six hundred thousand into
it and now you know you know we're
trying to decide whether to sell it and
just take our losses you know and go and
rent for a while and continue to sock
money in the bank or or to just continue
with the mortgage that just barely over
water mortgage is about 325
we've been appraised for about 425 on
the house so very very unusual for a
house that was worth six hundred
thousand before the crash to not be
worth six hundred thousand by now is
there other problems in your area it's
it's a pretty rural community and we're
probably at the top of the market there
at the time okay so you come back you
dramatically over built the market okay
now that would make some sense on how
there is so you've literally you have
six hundred thousand dollars in the
thing you owe three hundred on it yes we
put three hundred you put three hundred
of your money on it and you owe three
hundred on it and it will only bring
four and a quarter yeah okay so here's a
rule of thumb that is aggravating is
crud that hurts your feelings I get it
dirts mine too just listening to it I'm
sorry for you you do not analyze
investments though based on what you
have in them you analyze investments
based on what they're going to become
and so the way I ask the way you ask
yourself the question it's a sunk cost
analysis that's taught in Harvard
Business School and the sunk cost
analysis is a simple concept you ask
yourself if I didn't own it would I buy
it for that today and if the answer is
no because I don't think it has a
positive future then it's time to sell
it regardless of what I have in it so
the way you oppose it in this situation
is you
if I didn't own this house for 425
thousand dollars and I had $425,000
piled in the mill the kitchen table and
would I go buy this house today
well you're not excited about that local
economy going up at a reasonable rate
like other areas have done so you
probably would not buy it again today
for four hundred twenty five thousand
would you right which means you do need
to take that for it and sell it and just
take your losses okay if you're ready to
move if you're ready to move are you are
you ready to move I didn't I guess I
didn't ask that yeah we're ready you
don't like the house you don't like the
house you're you want to be living in a
different community your your leave
leaving and so forth yeah well we love
the house but unfortunately you know
it's just one of those things where I
turn 58 this year I'd like to be able to
retire at 62 and you know just don't see
continue to put $3,600 a month away in a
mortgage that leads to the next question
is do we go and rent somewhere or should
we buy I would definitely buy I'll just
move way down because your goal here is
to get the mortgage paid off in four
years what you just told me right yep
and so you got a hundred thousand bucks
or so in equity and we're gonna take
that and plow it into the next property
and whatever mortgage you take you're
gonna be really aggressive and you might
have $4,000 payments but at least
they're going to you know a five-year
plan or whatever it is to pay the house
off very very very quickly because that
meets with your goals are being
debt-free and that's going to limit the
property you buy the neighborhood you
buy in and so forth but that's you know
it hits your goals because you can't
have both you can't you know live high
on the hog and not pay the bill you got
to pay the bill to live there so you
just decide which of those ways you want
to go I'm with you that we get out of
debt as we move into retirement you know
if you want to retire in a nicer
property you might end up working a
couple more years just to cause that to
happen I don't know but because of this
problem that you've run into but if
that's not the house for you going
forward then today's as good a day as
any to sell it